Guys, I just wanted to say welcome. I'm so excited that you guys came here today on Armchair Expert. Yeah, and we're happy to be here. Yeah. I love the way Bateman, I love it. You're so easy going and you just don't seem like anything really bothers you. And Sean, you're such a funny guy and you always bring humor to every situation, but I reserve most of my disdain is for Barney, for Arnett.
伙计们，我只是想说欢迎。我很高兴你们今天能来“扶手椅专家”。是的，我们很高兴能来。是的。我喜欢贝特曼说话的方式，我太喜欢了。你太随和了，而且看起来好像没什么事能真的烦到你。肖恩，你太逗了，总能给每种情况带来幽默，但我把最大的鄙视留给了巴尼，留给了阿内特。
He's a bit of a deadweight. Hey, Dax, hang on. Yeah, well, what do you think about all that? I just, well, I'm finding it a little offensive. I'm a little put off by it. I don't mean that you're deadweight. I just mean that, like, you know, just seems like those other two do a lot more heavy lifting. That's true, but we love to have him.
他有点像个累赘。嘿，戴克斯，等等。好吧，你对这一切怎么看？我只是……好吧，我觉得这有点冒犯。我有点被它反感了。我不是说你是累赘。我只是觉得，你知道，那另外两个人好像干了更多重活。确实如此，但我们很喜欢有他在。
He's kind of like our mascot. If I close my eyes, it's like Dax and Will are here. It's simultaneously the best Dax Shepard impression and the worst. And I hope he's not insulted because I do it all out of love. I love the guy. I love, love, love the guy. So listen, listener, the bad news is you're not listening to Armchair Expert. The worst news is you are listening to SmartLess.
他有点像我们的吉祥物。如果我闭上眼睛，感觉就像戴克斯和威尔就在这里。这既是最好的戴克斯·谢泼德模仿秀，也是最差的。我希望他不会被冒犯，因为我这一切都是出于爱。我爱这家伙。我爱，爱，爱这家伙。所以听好了，听众朋友们，坏消息是你们听的不是“扶手椅专家”。更糟糕的消息是，你们听的是“聪明无极限”。
Can I just say this? Can I just do it? Because I'm here. Do you mind? Please. Welcome to SmartLess. Thank you. Smart, less. Smart, less.
我能说这个吗？我能直接开始吗？因为我在这儿。你介意吗？请便。欢迎来到“聪明无极限”。谢谢。聪明，无极限。聪明，无极限。
Smart, less. Hey guys, how about global warming? Is that a thing? Great way to start a show, Sean. You want everybody to be happy? Just trying to remind everybody how happy and great everything is. Are you complaining because the air conditioning doesn't work in your mansion? Yeah, it is hot.
聪明，无极限。嘿，伙计们，全球变暖怎么样？有这回事吗？真是个开场的好办法，肖恩。你想让每个人都高兴吗？只是想提醒大家一切是多么开心和美好。你在抱怨你的豪宅里空调坏了吗？对，是很热。
Yeah, what are you worried about? Are you... It's hot. It's hot. That's your explanation. It's summer. You know, it's summer. But there is, global warming is real.
对，你在担心什么？你在……很热。很热。这就是你的解释。是夏天。你知道的，是夏天。但确实有，全球变暖是真的。
Is that what you want to tell our listeners? It is real, if there was a doubt. Yeah. No, it is real. We believe it. And also, get vaccinated. I mean, we might as well if we're doing this. I mean...
这就是你想告诉我们的听众的吗？它是真的，如果以前还有怀疑的话。是的。不，它是真的。我们相信它。还有，去打疫苗。我的意思是，既然我们在说这个，那我们不妨顺便说一下。我是说……
Go down the list. No, I'm just saying if we're going down the list, I mean, these are things that I believe that are true. We're not a political show. The world is not flat either, but I have not independently verified that. That's another thing I'm hearing. I mean, I got up in an airplane the other day
顺着名单往下说。不，我只是说如果我们正顺着名单往下说，我的意思是，这些都是我认为正确的事情。我们不是一个政治节目。地球也不是平的，但我还没有独立证实这一点。这是我听到的另一件事。我的意思是，前几天我坐上一架飞机
and it still looked pretty flat, but I am hearing from people I respect, though, that if you got up even higher, it is round. Speaking about flat, you know, did you guys watch the Jeff Bezos thing that went off? You know, no, wait, listen, I'm serious. The rocket thing, right? I did not know this, that when the rocket,
它看起来还是挺平的，但我从我尊敬的人那里听说，如果你飞得更高一点，它是圆的。说到平，你知道吗，你们看了杰夫·贝佐斯发射那个东西了吗？你知道，不，等等，听着，我是认真的。那个火箭的事，对吧？我以前不知道这个，当火箭发射的时候，
because when we watched the thing go off, it looked like it's going straight up, but scientifically speaking, it's actually going parallel to the Earth. Well, after a bit. After a bit, it starts to tilt a little bit. No, no, no, no, no. It goes right away. It goes right away.
因为我们看着那玩意儿发射时，它看起来像是直直往上飞的，但从科学上讲，它实际上是与地球平行的。嗯，过了一会儿。过了一会儿，它开始稍微倾斜一点。不，不，不，不，不。它立刻就开始了。它立刻就开始了。
And the thing, and the idea is, if you think about it, the way they wait. Here come the fucking rocket scientists. Let's hear it, Jesus. Rockets go sideways. Sure. Right, because it has to do with gravity. I thought it went straight up.
那东西，而且这个想法是，如果你仔细想想，他们等待的方式。他妈的火箭科学家来了。让我们听听，耶稣。火箭是横着飞的。当然。对，因为这跟重力有关。我还以为它是直着往上飞的呢。
No. So we've covered space. We've covered what else in this, in the global warming. These are all issues. You know, I do learn a lot from you guys, you know? I need to sort of absorb knowledge in some other way than academia, because as you both know,
不。所以我们聊了太空。我们还聊了别的什么，在全球变暖里。这些都是问题。你知道的，我确实从你们身上学到了很多，你知道吗？我需要通过除了学术之外的其他方式来吸收知识，因为如你们俩所知，
that part of my life was cut a little short. Yeah, how short, by the way? Well, I got to the end of high school, except for two of my final four finals. So no college there. Two tests short. No, and a high school diploma short. You know, I was thinking, Jason, about you,
我那段人生被搞得有点短。对，顺便问一下，有多短？嗯，我念到了高中结束，除了我最后四个期末考试里的两个。所以没上过大学。差两门考试。不，还差一个高中毕业证。你知道的，我在想，杰森，关于你，
because we've talked about you and your fascination with school and with college. We've talked about it over a couple episodes, right? Yeah, that I want to know if it's hard. Yeah, you were worried it's hard. And I'm surprised. I'm surprised that you would be scared, because I would think it's just more information.
因为我们聊过你对学校和大学的迷恋。我们在好几期节目里都聊过，对吧？对，我想知道它是不是很难。对，你担心它很难。我很惊讶。我很惊讶你会感到害怕，因为我以为那只是更多的信息。
And we know that you have a propensity, you have an ability to... Just sound it out. To retain. Yep. Yeah, so you know how to retain. I mean, look at your face right now. Oh, see, Shawn, you just need to wait a little while,
我们知道你有一种倾向，你有一种能力去…… 读出来。去记住。没错。是的，所以你知道怎么去记住。我的意思是，看看你现在的脸。哦，看，肖恩，你只需要再等一会儿，
and then you'll be hurt, you know? You just got to be patient. Oh, I've been patient for 20 years. And it'll land. It'll hit you right in the gut. Your retention is off the charts today. Well, let me tell you something with the heat wave that we're dealing with here in Los Angeles.
然后你就会受伤，你知道吗？你只需要有耐心。哦，我已经耐心了20年了。它会降临的。它会正中你的要害。你今天的记忆力简直爆表。好吧，让我告诉你们一些关于我们在洛杉矶面临的热浪的事。
It is great for my water weight problems. Is it as hot where you are, Will, there in Long Island? It is. It's hot here right now, and it's very moist. Yeah, it's moist out here too. Is it moist there? Yeah, it's humid. I would much rather freeze than sweat.
这对我的水分滞留问题太棒了。威尔，你在长岛那里，也这么热吗？是的。这里现在很热，而且非常潮湿。对，我们这儿也很潮湿。你们那儿潮湿吗？对，很闷热。我宁愿冻着也不愿出汗。
How about you, fellas? Yeah, 1,000%. Wait, so hang on, what are we... What are we doing? We're talking a bunch of bullshit. Let's get into something that's worth listening to. Today, we have a person joining us that is a critical voice on where we are politically,
你们呢，伙计们？对，百分之一千。等等，所以等等，我们在……我们在干什么？我们在扯一堆淡。让我们聊点值得听的话题吧。今天，有一位嘉宾加入了我们，她是我们所处的政治立场、
where we have been, where we are going. She has been a journalist for 25 years. She's worked on Obama's campaign. She's graduated from Harvard for God's sake. She has her own cable news show. She's got incredible style, three kids, and most importantly, a husband named Jason. Folks, this is the treasure named Joy Reed.
我们曾经在哪里、我们将去何方的关键发声者。她做过25年的记者。她曾为奥巴马的竞选工作。看在上帝的份上，她毕业于哈佛。她有自己的有线新闻节目。她有着令人难以置信的风格，三个孩子，最重要的是，她的丈夫叫杰森。伙计们，这就是那个名叫乔·里德的宝藏。
Joy? No. Welcome. Joy Reed. Joy! There she is. Well, hello there. I'm just gonna dork out here for a second.
乔？不。欢迎。乔·里德。乔！她在那儿。哦，大家好。我只想在这里犯傻一下下。
I'm gonna just fan out on you. I spend more time with you than I do my family. I'm every single day, truly. This is so cool. You're here. It's so nice to meet you. I know. It's so cool to be with you guys.
我只想变成你的粉丝。我和你在一起的时间比和我家人在一起的时间还多。我真的，每天都是如此。太酷了。你来了。很高兴见到你。我懂。能和你们在一起太酷了。
Very excited. One of the interesting things I did in my terrible research that I do for my guests, it's just simply Wikipedia, is that you studied film. Did you have a film degree? I did. Yeah, I graduated with a Bachelor of Arts in film.
非常兴奋。我在为我的嘉宾做的那份糟糕的研究中发现的一件有趣的事——那其实只是维基百科——就是你学过电影。你是有电影学位吗？我是。对，我获得了一个电影专业的文学学士学位。
Basically, documentary film is what I wound up studying. From where? At Harvard. They call it visual and environmental studies, so no one will know what it is. Just to make it sound as boring as possible. Yes. It was to discourage us from going Hollywood.
基本上，我最后学的是纪录片电影。从哪儿？哈佛。他们把它叫做视觉与环境研究，这样就没人知道那是什么了。只是为了让它听起来尽可能无聊。是的。这是为了阻止我们去好莱坞。
Is that where you met Jason? Because he's a documentary. Yeah, no, actually, I met him afterwards. So basically, they try to hide Hollywood under a bushel. They don't want any of us to aspire to that. So their film degree is called Visual Environmental Studies. They put the photography majors, the film majors all in there,
你就是在那儿遇到杰森的吗？因为他是个纪录片……对，不，其实我是后来遇到他的。所以基本上，他们试图把好莱坞藏在箩筐底下。他们不希望我们任何人去向往那个。所以他们的电影学位叫视觉环境研究。他们把摄影专业的、电影专业的全塞进里面，
and then you study a lot of theory and in some filmmaking you do your final thesis film. I actually met Jason because when I graduated, I had these sort of dreams of being the girl Spike Lee and I took a job at School of Visual Arts in the production office as the manager of the production office and Jason, who had taken a year off.
然后你学习大量的理论，在一些电影制作中你还要做你的毕业论文电影。我其实遇到杰森是因为我毕业时，有那种成为女斯派克·李的梦想，我在视觉艺术学院的制作办公室找了份工作，担任制作办公室经理，而杰森休学了一年。
So he was one year behind me. He was basically my employee inside the production office. That's how I met him. At SVA in New York? Yeah, yeah. Wow. That's so cool. I love in your background,
所以他比我低一级。他基本上就是我在制作办公室里的手下。我就是这么认识他的。在纽约的SVA？对，对。哇。太酷了。我喜欢在你的背景里，
there's a little bag that says Book Nerd on it. Explain to these guys what a book is. Yeah, that's a bag you'd never see in my house. Tell me, like growing up. It'd be empty, the bag would be empty. What do you mean? What was your, did you grow, did you feel like a nerd growing up
有一个写着“书呆子”的小包。给这些家伙解释一下什么是书。对，那是你在我家绝对见不到的包。告诉我，比如成长过程中的事。会是空的，那个包会是空的。什么意思？你成长过程中，觉得自己像个书呆子吗，
and were you treated as one? Oh, totally, totally. Yeah, no, I was very nerdy. As a kid, I loved, you know, I did the crossword puzzle on Sunday in the newspaper. I mean, the only things I was really interested in. You could do Sundays? I was really good at it.
你被当成书呆子对待过吗？哦，完全是，完全是。对，不，我非常书呆子气。小时候，我喜欢，你知道的，我周日在报纸上做纵横字谜。我的意思是，我真正感兴趣的只有这些。你连周日的都能做？我真的很擅长。
I sometimes would have like one thing missing. I still can't get past Monday. Come on. Really? Yeah. Are you serious? I try Tuesdays every once in a while, but I never feel good about myself.
我有时会漏掉一个地方。我至今还是过不了周一那一关。拜托。真的吗？对。你是认真的吗？我偶尔会尝试周二的，但我从来没觉得自己好过。
Yeah. It's tough for me. I'm gonna end this. They're hard. They're hard. Thank you, Joy. And the references are like weird cultural stuff. Yeah, it's weird.
对。这对我来说太难了。我要结束这个。它们很难。它们很难。谢谢你，乔。而且里面的典故都是些奇怪的文化梗。对，很奇怪。
I can do it. No, I'll bet you can't, Will. Now the reading, how much reading do you get a chance to do nowadays with your busy schedule? Well, I don't get to read. I mean, you can have a whole wall of books behind me. I mean, I don't get a chance to read as much as I would like to unless I have a book, you know,
我能做。不，我打赌你不能，威尔。现在说到阅读，顶着你忙碌的日程，你现在能有多少机会阅读呢？好吧，我没空阅读。我的意思是，我身后有一整面墙的书。我的意思是，我没有机会像我希望的那样阅读，除非我要采访一本……
an author on, I do try to read their books if I'm gonna have them on. But because I have to read all day, just the news of day stuff. I used to do a weekend show. It was so much more leisurely to be able to like read a whole book. Now I can barely cram in all the reading for every day.
采访一位作家，如果我要请他们来，我确实会尽量读他们的书。但因为我整天都得阅读，全都是当天的突发新闻。我以前做过一个周末节目。能有机会读完整本书要悠闲得多。现在我几乎塞不下每天要读的所有东西了。
So I don't have as much time. And are you fully, are you and your gang over there, are you guys fully reliant on New York Times, Washington Post, or do you have special access to information to build your news from? Or do you just expose the same stuff that we are? No, we luckily have, MSNBC, you know, is part of NBCUniversal.
所以我没有那么多时间。而且你们，你和你那边的那帮人，你们是完全依赖《纽约时报》、《华盛顿邮报》，还是你们有获取信息的特殊渠道来建立你们的新闻？或者你们只是曝光跟我们一样的东西？不，我们很幸运，MSNBC，你知道的，它是NBC环球的一部分。
So we, thank God, have NBC News. We have a whole political unit. So there's enough, you know, independent reporting and political reporters. We have a whole team that's at Capitol Hill. I actually now, now that I'm a DC based show, we're literally like steps away from Capitol Hill. So we have that.
所以我们，感谢上帝，拥有NBC新闻。我们有一个完整的政治部门。所以有足够的，你知道的，独立报道和政治记者。我们有一个完整的团队在国会山。我其实现在，既然我是一个总部在华盛顿的节目，我们简直离国会山只有几步之遥。所以我们有这个。
Plus I have my own sources. I spend a lot of time texting people who are in politics who are in campaigns. So we try to do as much as we can on our own. And our show producers are very aggressive about calling people. And so we don't just rely on like the time. Yeah, Jason, they're not getting their news
另外我还有我自己的消息源。我花很多时间给那些在政坛、在竞选团队的人发短信。所以我们尽量靠我们自己做尽可能多的事情。我们的节目制作人非常积极地给别人打电话。所以我们不只是依赖像时代……对，杰森，他们获取新闻不是从其他新闻源来的。
from other news sources. They're the ones who are in, how do you think this works? It's got to come from somewhere. I don't have smarts. That's why we invest. And then you guys just write down stuff from CNN. Did you just copy it?
他们才是身处其中、你觉得这到底是怎么运作的？它肯定得从某个地方来。我没有聪明才智。这就是我们进行投资的原因。然后你们就只是把CNN的东西抄下来？你们是直接复制的吗？
It is? What the fuck do you think is going on here? You just support it as your own. So Joy, you mentioned sources. So I'm gonna tread lightly here because I know that you'd limited in what you can say. But I am fascinated. How much does it differ from what we see in movies?
是吗？你他妈以为这儿在发生什么？你们只是把它当成你们自己的支持物。所以乔，你提到了消息源。所以我在这里要小心翼翼，因为我知道你在能说的话方面受到限制。但我很着迷。这跟我们在电影里看到的有多大不同？
With deep throat, you meet Hal Holbrook in the garage. When reporters have sources, and especially now that there's a risk about people hacking your phone and finding out numbers and not a risk, it's a fact. Do you ever meet a source like in person or is it all like an encrypted digital or a combination of both?
比如《深喉》，你在车库里见哈尔·霍布鲁克。当记者有消息源时，尤其是现在人们有手机被黑客入侵和号码被泄露的风险——不是风险，这是事实——你有没有在现实中见过消息源，还是全都是加密的数字通信，或者是两者的结合？
Raincoats, do you have? And are you meeting in in garages? I have all the raincoats. Well, I also have to make it fashion. So I need a lot of raincoats. They have to have them for every color. No, we're gonna get into your style. No, so we spend a lot of time with sources
雨衣，你们有吗？你们是在车库里见面吗？我有所有的雨衣。好吧，我也得让它时尚。所以我需要很多雨衣。每种颜色都得备一件。不，我们要聊聊你的风格。不，所以我们花很多时间与消息源接触，
like either on signal or WhatsApp. You have to be careful. You can't just text people as much as you used to because as you said, also the government can subpoena them. But especially in the last year because of COVID, everything is digital. Everything is text, everything is signal.
比如通过Signal或WhatsApp。你必须小心。你不能像以前那样随便给别人发短信，因为正如你所说，政府也可以传唤他们。但特别是在过去的一年里，因为疫情，一切都是数字化的。一切都是短信，一切都是Signal。
It's very little in person. And what is the competition like to secure one of these sources? I would imagine, let's say when Biden was coming in or it looked like he was gonna get it and you start to hear about who the cabinet's gonna be and how the rest of the government's gonna be staffed up. Is there like a race to like,
面对面交流非常少。为了确保获得这些消息源之一，竞争有多激烈？我可以想象，比如说当拜登即将上任，或者看起来他要赢了，然后你开始听到内阁会是谁，政府其他部门将如何配备人员。有没有这样一种竞争，
oh, that's gonna be a great source potentially because they're gonna have good access and you might bump into somebody trying to get that same source, maybe somebody from CNN or like, how does all that work? Is there a drama there? The only way that it works that way is for instance, in the case of like a trial,
哦，那可能是一个很好的消息源，因为他们能接触到高层，而你可能会碰巧遇到也在争取那个消息源的人，也许是CNN的人，或者，这一切是如何运作的？那里有戏剧性吗？唯一这样运作的情况是，例如，在审判的案子里，
like let's say the Derek Chauvin trial, everyone wants to know who are all these jurors? How do we get to them? Or if there's a Black Lives Matter case, we all wanna connect with the family. We all wanna talk to them. In that sense, the non-political sources. For me personally, I don't like access journalism.
比方说德里克·肖万的审判，每个人都想知道这些陪审员都是谁？我们怎么联系到他们？或者如果有一个“黑人的命也是命”的案子，我们都想和家属建立联系。我们都想和他们谈谈。从这个意义上说，这是非政治性的消息源。就我个人而言，我不喜欢“接触新闻”。
I don't think it's a good way to do journalism to just try to find out who that person is in that office. And because what they're gonna tell you is what the office wants you to know. That's not really giving you anything that the public needs. The whole idea behind what Woodward and Bernstein did, they didn't get access. They got somebody who was telling information
我不认为这是一种好的新闻报道方式，去试图找出那个办公室里的那个人是谁。因为他们要告诉你的是办公室想让你知道的。那并没有真正给你提供任何公众需要的东西。伍德沃德和伯恩斯所做的事情背后的整个理念，他们不是为了获取接触渠道。他们找的是一个会透露信息的人，
that the government didn't want us to know. So I really am against the idea of trying to scurry in and find out who are gonna be the key people to talk to in the administration. There are people who do that. That's a part of the job for some parts of journalism. But I'm not at the NBC News. I'm more of an opinion journalist.
而那些信息是政府不想让我们知道的。所以我真的很反对那种急于跑进去找出谁是政府中关键对话人物的想法。确实有人这样做。那是新闻业某些部分的工作的一部分。但我不在NBC新闻。我更倾向于观点型记者。
So basically I've developed these sources for basically friends that I've made over years and years from working in campaigns. These are people I've known forever. And sometimes they're in an administration and then sometimes they come out. These are people that are just people I know. And so they can get me information
所以我基本上开发这些消息源，靠的是我多年来在竞选工作中结交的朋友。这些是我永远认识的人。有时他们在政府里，有时他们退居幕后。这些人只是我认识的人。所以他们能为我获取信息，
that the government maybe doesn't want you to have. You know what I'm saying? So I just rely on my personal relationships. I also have a lot of Republican friends and relationships because they're people who I've known and combated with like Michael Steele, that's been a friend of mine for a long time. Since we used to battle,
而政府可能不想让你知道。你知道我在说什么吗？所以我只是依靠我的个人关系。我也有很多共和党朋友和关系，因为他们是我认识并与之战斗过的人，比如迈克尔·斯蒂尔，他很久以来一直是我的朋友。自从我们过去交锋以来，
we ultimately, because we respected each other, became friends. So I have Republican sources and Democratic. I know it's wild how far he's traveled. So it's really to me, it's more relationships. I'm saying sources, but I really just mean I have relationships. Yeah. And now, back to the show.
最终，因为我们尊重彼此，我们成了朋友。所以我有共和党的消息源，也有民主党的消息源。我知道他走过了这么远的路，真是疯狂。所以对我和我来说，这更多是关于关系。我说的是消息源，但我其实只是指我有人际关系。对。现在，回到节目中。
Okay, Joy, I wanna ask you something and keep in mind, I am the least smart of the smart list group here. Agreed. So I'm asking for me and the people who don't. Sorry, I gotta let him get the statement out first. You got a debate and wanted. No, I'm sorry. But you're also the funniest.
好吧，乔，我想问你一件事，请记住，我是这里“聪明无极限”组合中最不聪明的一个。同意。所以我是在为我和那些不懂的人问。抱歉，我得让他先把话说完。你有个辩论想打。不，对不起。但你也是最搞笑的。
We'll build a gap in there. Joy, how dare you? He is the funniest. But I see this phrase thrown around recently and I truly am asking you because I don't know the ins and out of it. I know. What is EDM?
我们在中间留个空隙。乔，你怎么敢？他最搞笑了。但我看到最近流传着这样一个词组，我是真心在问你，因为我不知道它的内幕和外延。我懂。什么是EDM？
No, I know kind of like a broad stroke of what it is, but what is critical race theory? Oh my God, I had that question. Thank you, please. Yeah. So again, and I say this not as an expert in critical race theory, which I always lead with because the only people who are real experts
不，我大概知道它宏观上的意思是什么，但什么是批判性种族理论？哦，天哪，我正想问这个问题。谢谢，请讲。对。所以，再说一次，我并不是以批判性种族理论专家的身份说这话的——我总是以此作为开场白，因为真正的专家
in critical race theory are lawyers, because it's something you learn in law school. So critical race theory was a body of legal theory that grew in the late 1980s at Harvard University when Derek Bell was a professor there. And as a Harvard Law School professor, he and people like Kimberly Crenshaw, who was his student, went on to ask themselves,
只有律师，因为这是你在法学院学的东西。所以批判性种族理论是一套法律理论体系，它在20世纪80年代末发源于哈佛大学，当时德里克·贝尔在那里担任教授。作为哈佛法学院教授，他和金伯利·克伦肖（当时是他的学生）等人开始问自己：
when you look at American history, what was built into the legal system and the laws that made us unequal and brought us to the point where even the Civil Rights and Voting Rights Acts have not produced material equality. When you look at all the stats and you see all the ways in which we are still racially unequal in this country, white versus not white people, they were asking themselves,
当你审视美国历史时，法律系统和法律中究竟内置了什么，导致了我们的不平等，并把我们带到了这样一个地步——甚至连《民权法案》和《投票权法案》都没有产生实质上的平等。当你查看所有的数据，看到我们在国内依然在 racial（种族）上不平等的种种方式——白人对非白人，他们当时在问自己：
well, what is it that we can look at in history that brought us to this in the laws? So what critical race theory is, is a way of looking at the legal system and asking what components of it are institutionally structured to keep inequality going. That's all it is. It has nothing to do with saying white people are,
嗯，我们在历史的法律中能看到什么导致了这一切？所以批判性种族理论，就是一种审视法律系统并询问其哪些组件在制度上被结构化以维持不平等的方式。这就是全部。它与声称白人是……
as a matter of fact, it's funny, the argument that it says white people are inherently racist can't be true because critical race theorists believe, and because it's true, that race isn't real, because it isn't. Race is a social construct. It isn't a biological fact. There's nothing different.
事实上，这很有趣，那种认为它说白人天生就是种族主义者的观点是不成立的，因为批判性种族理论家们相信——而且这也是事实——种族并不是真实的，因为本就不是。种族是一种社会建构。它不是一个生物学事实。没有什么不同。
If we peeled our skin off, we're all the same. Race is cultural, it's sort of tribal, but it's like saying a brown dog and a white dog are not both the same species, right? There's no, race isn't real. You can take a brown dog and a tan dog, and they are perfectly can make a medium color dog, right? People are just like any other mammal,
如果我们把皮肤剥掉，我们都是一样的。种族是文化的，有点像部落性质的，但这就像是说棕色的狗和白色的狗不是同一个物种一样，对吧？没有，种族不是真的。你可以把一只棕色的狗和一只黄褐色的狗放在一起，它们完全可以生出一只中等颜色的狗，对吧？人类就像任何其他哺乳动物一样，
we're just one species, but people in this country invented race, and literally critical race theorists, it's in the thing if you read the Harvard description of it, says race isn't real, it's a social construct. So you can't say anyone is inherently racist. So how do we uninvent it? That's a great point.
我们只有一个物种，但这个国家的人发明了种族，而字面意义上的批判性种族理论家——如果你读哈佛对它的描述，里面就会提到——种族不是真的，它是一种社会建构。所以你不能说任何人天生就是种族主义者。那么我们该如何“取消”这种发明呢？这真是个好观点。
I don't believe in even mentioning it. So my thing is what I debated this foolish dude who was so dumb, he bragged about his strategy. He said, I don't give a shit about critical race theory. I'm just gonna use it and attach every crazy story about awkward ways teachers try to teach anti-racism and call it critical race theory. I refuse to debate these people
我甚至不相信去提及它。所以我的看法是，我曾与一个愚蠢至极的家伙辩论，他竟然为自己的策略吹嘘。他说，我才不在乎什么批判性种族理论呢。我就是要用它，把所有关于老师们试图教授反种族主义的笨拙方式的疯狂故事都贴上这个标签，并称之为批判性种族理论。我拒绝跟这些人辩论
on something they made up. Don't debate it. If you ain't a critical race theory expert, don't debate them on that. You should just talk about the things they wanna do, which is book banning, idea banning, teacher mandates. And so I would just not debate them on critical race theory. I don't, I refuse to.
他们凭空捏造的东西。不要去辩论。如果你不是批判性种族理论专家，就不要跟他们辩论那个。你只应该谈论他们想做的事情，也就是禁书、禁思想、强推教师指令。所以我干脆不跟他们辩论批判性种族理论。我不会，我拒绝。
Yeah, it makes me think of something that, again, I'd love your take on it. So at what point is it too young to even introduce to a new mind the notion that at one point, the white folks saw the black folks as less than? Because as soon as you introduce that idea to this pure mind, maybe some white kids
是的，这让我想起了一件事，再次声明，我很想听听你的看法。那么，在什么年龄把这样一个概念引入一个全新的心智算太小呢？——即白人曾经把黑人视为低人一等。因为一旦你把这个概念引入这纯洁的心灵，也许一些处于糟糕环境中的白人孩子，
that are in a bad environment, will try that thought on and incorporate it and go, oh, you know what? Yeah, so like in other words, if they never had that notion, would an instinct of racism ever take hold? Did any of that make sense? It does make sense.
会去尝试这个想法，将其内化，然后说：“哦，你知道吗？是的。”换句话说，如果他们从来没有过这种观念，种族主义的本能还会占上风吗？刚才这些话有道理吗？确实有道理。
And I think that's a valid question. I think here's the challenge. They, back in the 19, I wanna say 50s or 60s, they did a thing called the doll test in which they took little kids, like second and third graders, and they gave them an array of dolls, black kids. And they said, would you rather play
我认为这是一个有效的问题。我认为这里的挑战在于：他们在19世纪——我想应该是50年代或60年代——做过一个叫做“洋娃娃测试”的实验，他们让小孩子，比如二年级和三年级的孩子，接触一系列洋娃娃，这些是黑人小孩。他们问，你更愿意和
with this little doll who is white or this little doll who is black? And like 90% of them said they wanted to play with the white doll. And this was consistent over years and years and years of doing it, meaning that even by second, third grade, black children have internalized the idea that black is ugly, that black is inferior.
这个白人小娃娃玩，还是这个黑人小娃娃玩？大约90%的孩子说他们想和白人娃娃玩。而且多年来的反复测试结果都始终如此，这意味着甚至到了二、三年级，黑人儿童就已经内化了“黑色是丑陋的”、“黑色是低人一等的”这种观念。
They've already internalized it. So we're talking second graders. Similarly to that, my kids, I raised them in Florida. We lived in New York, but we moved to Florida when our two older ones were toddler, where I was pregnant with my second one. And all three of our kids were pretty much raised in Florida. By the time they were in the fourth grade,
他们已经内化了。所以我们谈论的是二年级的孩子。与此类似，我的孩子们，我是在佛罗里达把他们抚养长大的。我们在纽约住过，但当我们的两个大孩子还在蹒跚学步时，我们搬到了佛罗里达，当时我正怀着我的第二个孩子。我们的三个孩子基本上都是在佛罗里达长大的。到了他们上四年级的时候，
they had been called the N-word by other kids. So those kids were, and in the case of the kids who called my kids the N-word, they were not even white. They were brown kids, they were Colombian. And I had to go and surprise their parents with my Spanish and tell the mother off, right? Which she was very shocked by. But the bottom line is little kids are already practicing
他们就已经被别的孩子叫做N开头的那个侮辱性词汇了。所以那些孩子，而且在那些叫我孩子N开头的词的孩子的情况中，他们甚至不是白人。他们是棕色人种的孩子，是哥伦比亚人。我不得不去用我的西班牙语给他们的父母一个惊吓，把那个母亲狠狠教训了一顿，对吧？她对此感到非常震惊。但底线是，小孩子们已经在对其他小孩子以及对自己践行
racism on other little kids and on themselves and internalizing self-hate. So you can't- Right, I was gonna say it starts at home. Well, the thing is, is that even if you say, well, I won't teach it at school, believe me when I tell you, black kids are already internalizing inferiority and white kids are internalizing superiority
种族主义，并内化自我仇恨了。所以你不能……对，我本来想说这始于家庭。嗯，事情是这样的，即使你说“我不在学校教这个”，相信我的话，黑人孩子到三年级时已经在内化自卑感，而白人孩子在三年级时也已经在内化优越感了。
by the time they get to the third grade. So it isn't to say that there's some young age where you can't teach it, they're already getting it. They're getting it from TV commercials. They're getting it from the way that black people are depicted on the news when they walk by the news and they see all the criminals are black. But they're not getting the N-word from TV commercials.
所以并不是说有什么太小的年龄是你不能教的，他们已经在接触这些了。他们是从电视广告里接触到的。他们是从新闻中对黑人的描绘方式中接触到的，当他们走过新闻画面时，看到所有的罪犯都是黑人。但他们可不是从电视广告里听到N开头的那个词的。
They're getting that from home. They're getting that from people. They're getting it from other kids too. Trust me, they're getting it from other kids too. So then this would be in support of the case of teaching it as early as possible to offset all the crap at home. Yes, and the thing is, is the better you can do to teach anti-racism to kids
他们是从家里听来的。他们是从别人那里听来的。他们也是从其他孩子那里听来的。相信我，他们也是从其他孩子那里听来的。那么这就支持了尽早教授这一概念，以对冲家里那些垃圾言论的做法？是的，而且事情是这样的，你越是能向孩子们教授反种族主义，
and to teach the truth at an age level. Remember, I mean, I took my kids to church when they were kids and the church we went to had like a kiddie version of the message and a grownup version of the message because they know a kid has a different brain. The Ruby Bridges book that they're trying to ban in Tennessee is written as a children's book.
并在适合年龄的水平上教授真相，就越好。记住，我的意思是，我以前带我的孩子去教堂，我们去的教堂有针对儿童的简化版布道，也有针对成年人的完整版布道，因为他们知道孩子的大脑是不同的。他们试图在田纳西州禁掉的那个鲁比·布里奇斯的书，就是作为儿童读物写的。
It's a children's book. It's not written as a, let me lecture y'all about racism from an adult point of view. It's written from a point of view of a child. So the thing is, is you can have children's books that teach things about different families. They're books they used to wanna ban about teaching different families.
它是一本儿童读物。它不是用那种“让我从成年人的角度向你们唠叨种族主义”的口吻写的。它是从孩子的视角写的。所以事情是这样的，你可以拥有教授不同家庭的儿童读物。那些他们曾经想要禁掉的关于教授不同家庭的书。
What if you're a little kid and you have two moms and no one else in your class can experience that? Are you saying we shouldn't have a children's book in the second, third grade that teaches that your family is normal? You know what I mean? And we had that fight in Florida, a major fight. They're like, these kids are too young to internalize that.
如果你是个小孩子，你有两个妈妈，而你班上其他人体验不到这一点，怎么办？你是说我们在二、三年级不应该有一本儿童读物来教导你的家庭是正常的吗？你知道我的意思吗？我们在佛罗里达经历过这场大战，一场大战。他们觉得，这些孩子们太小了，无法内化这一点。
But some of the kids are living that, right? They have two dads or two moms and you say it's too young to introduce this concept. You're not like saying, let's show like a porn. You're saying, let's like actually talk about their family. So I don't think any kid is too young to start getting the message that look, nobody's perfect. And they're more visual.
但有些孩子正在经历这些，对吧？他们有两个爸爸或两个妈妈，而你却说介绍这个概念为时过早。你又不是在说，让我们放个色情片。你是在说，让我们实际谈谈他们的家庭。所以我认为没有哪个孩子太小，以至于不能开始接受这样的信息：听着，没有人是完美的。而且他们视觉思维更强。
Your mom and dad aren't perfect. No one's perfect, right? And so if you can teach in a way that's very picture driven, very image driven to say, you know, the ways that we have black people and white people and brown people in this country is the way that we brought them here differently. And you might have come here as an immigrant
你的爸爸妈妈也不是完美的。没有人是完美的，对吧？所以如果你能用一种非常依赖图画、非常依赖图像的方式来教学，去说，你知道的，我们这个国家有黑人、白人和棕色人种，我们来到这里的方式是不同的。你可能是作为移民来到这里的，
and your family, other kids who are brown and black may have come here enslaved. And that was a bad, bad thing. And that was not a good thing. But here's the thing, we changed. And you can talk about the redemption of the country, but you can talk about it in a way that also tells the truth. I hate that people don't want the truth.
而你的家庭，其他棕色和黑色皮肤的孩子可能是作为奴隶被带到这里的。那是一件非常、非常糟糕的事情。那不是一件好事。但事情是这样的，我们改变了。你可以谈论这个国家的救赎，但你可以用一种同样说出真相的方式来谈论它。我很讨厌人们不想要真相。
You know, it's so funny that, well, not funny, but what's so strange for me is growing up in Canada, we is a different experience. The notion of racism obviously isn't solely American. It does exist in other places as well. Yeah. It's something that's been really perfected. It's one of the few things we started and didn't steal.
你知道，很有趣的是——或者说谈不上有趣，但对我来说非常奇怪的是——在加拿大长大，我们的经历是不同的。种族主义的观念显然不只是美国的。它在其他地方也存在。是的。这是一种真正被完美化的东西。这是我们开创且没有偷来的少数几样东西之一。
No, it's been perfected in this country. It's one of the, but I will say, and as a Canadian, you come here and I was 20 when I moved to this country and I was kind of shocked by it all. I couldn't, and I grew up with American TV and stuff, but it wasn't until I actually lived here that I was like, holy crap, this is-
不，它在这个国家被完美化了。它是其中之一，但我必须说，作为一个加拿大人，你来到这里——我搬到这个国家时20岁，我对这一切有点震惊。我简直不敢相信，虽然我看着美国电视长大什么的，但直到我真正住在这里，我才觉得，天呐，这是——
More blatant here. It's way more blatant. My husband is British. And he, well, he's always says, you know, my mother used to say it too because she lived in England for a long time. And she said, look, there's lots of racism in England. It's just more subtle
这里更明目张胆。这里明目张胆得多。我丈夫是英国人。他，嗯，他总是说，你知道，我母亲也这么说过，因为她在英国住过很长时间。她说，听着，英国有大量的种族主义。它只是更微妙一些，
because it's such a class-based system that you more get hit on class than on race on a daily basis. You don't feel it battering you. And she came here in 1960 and it didn't batter her until she got here and wanted to come here. Cause they all, you know, people outside,
因为那是一个高度基于阶级的系统，所以在日常生活中，你更多受到阶级而不是种族的打击。你不会觉得它在持续殴打你。她是在1960年来到这里的，直到她来到这里并想要融入之前，它都没有殴打过她。因为他们都，你知道，外面的人，
my parents are both immigrants and they really believe the ideas that they read about, about America. And they come here thinking, I'm gonna get a great education. My kids will have an opportunity. I mean, hell, my mother's first generation of her kids, one is a actress, one of them is a broadcaster
我的父母都是移民，他们真的相信他们读到的关于美国的那些理念。他们来到这里时心想，我会接受很好的教育。我的孩子们会有机会。见鬼，我母亲的孩子们里的第一代人，一个是演员，一个是广播员，
and one of them is a TV. You know, as a prime time TV show. Like it does happen, but she experienced racism big time in New York and was shocked by it. Yeah, in New York. Where did your parents immigrate from? My mother came from Guyana
还有一个是电视节目的。你知道，作为黄金时段的电视节目。这确实发生了，但她在纽约经历了非常严重的种族主义，并为此感到震惊。对，在纽约。你的父母是从哪里移民来的？我母亲来自圭亚那，
and my father was from the Congo, the Democratic Republic of Congo. Oh, wow, cool. Wow. Yeah. And he was a major Republican. They used to fight. They didn't, you know, the marriage clearly didn't last.
我父亲来自刚果，也就是刚果民主共和国。哦，哇，酷。哇。对。而且他是个坚定的共和党人。他们过去常常吵架。他们没有，你知道，这段婚姻显然没有持续下去。
He was a conservative Republican leaning guy and she was like a liberal pro-Carter, you know, Democrat. And so they were just very opposite. So Joy, speaking of showbiz, congratulations on your one year. Is it coming up on one year anniversary of your show? One year, we're coming up on the 12th of July. Oh, that's great.
他是一个倾向于保守派共和党的人，而她是一个自由派、支持卡特的民主党人。所以他们极其合不来。所以乔，说到娱乐圈，祝贺你的节目开播一周年。是不是快迎来你节目的四周岁——一周年纪念了？一周年，我们快迎来7月12日了。哦，太棒了。
Congrats. It's incredible. We just had ours. We can celebrate every year at the same time. Congratulations. One year. Yeah, so obviously when you guys launched, there was different, let's say,
恭喜。太不可思议了。我们刚刚过了我们的。我们每年可以在同一时间庆祝。恭喜。一周年。对，所以很显然，当你们推出节目时，有不同的，比方说，
let's say programming opportunities for you guys. This whole sort of dumpster fire. Are you guys fine? I don't mean to ask this in a cynical way, but are you guys finding your conversations about programming the episodes, and I'm sure across all news networks and shows, that the attempt to still try to hold
比方说你们的节目企划机会。整个这个烂摊子。你们还好吗？我不是以愤世嫉俗的方式问这个问题，但你们有没有发现，你们关于策划剧集的谈话——我确信在所有新闻网络和节目中——那种试图依然紧紧抓住
the audience's interest, does that go into your thoughts about what leads and what doesn't? Yeah, you know, when we took the show, I was in the midst of, look, again, I'm an opinion journalist. I'm not on nightly news. So I'm allowed to have an opinion. And my dedication, my only mission was to see to it
观众兴趣的尝试，会影响到你们对什么作为头条、什么不作为头条的思考吗？是的，你知道，当我们接手这个节目时，我正处于——听着，再说一次，我是个观点型记者。我不在晚间新闻。所以我允许有观点。而我的奉献，我唯一的使命就是确保
that I did everything in my power to prevent him from getting reelected because I genuinely believe had he been reelected, he would never leave. And he is an autocrat. Michael Cohen has said that very clearly. Everyone I know who knows him has said it very clearly. He is an autocrat.
我尽我所能阻止他再次当选，因为我真心相信，如果他再次当选，他将永远不会离开。他是一个独裁者。迈克尔·科恩说得很清楚。所有我认识的了解他的人都说得很清楚。他是一个独裁者。
He wants to be president for life. He's dangerous. And so my whole dedication was that. Huh, absolutely. Well, let me just, let me change the subject slightly here. Now, Joy, I don't spend a lot of time on style websites, as it might become as a surprise to most people, but I hope that you're getting the kind of feedback
他想终身担任总统。他很危险。所以我全部的奉献都在于此。哈，绝对的。好吧，让我，让我稍微换个话题。现在，乔，我并不经常花时间浏览时尚网站，这对大多数人来说可能有点意外，但我希望你能得到你应得的那种反馈、
and rewards and accolades that you deserve for, I mean, what's going on with your outfits is incredible. But what's going on, the hairstyle, every episode you're changing, it's just like, where does all this come from? Tell me about your team and where do you get your ideas? And I mean, you know. Yes, give credit to the team.
回报和赞誉，因为——我的天，你的服装太不可思议了。但是怎么回事，发型，你每一集都在变，这简直就像，这一切都从哪儿来？跟我聊聊你的团队，你从哪儿得到你的灵感？我的意思是，你知道的。是的，给团队点赞。
Yeah. Let's see what the team means. Yes, give credit to the team. So let me give credit to the team. So first of all, for an entire year, I had to do my own hair and makeup. And I am a legit tomboy. The only other thing I was doing when I was a kid,
让我们看看团队意味着什么。是的，给团队点赞。所以，让我给团队点赞。首先，整整一年，我都得自己弄头发和化妆。而我是一个名副其实的假小子。我小时候唯一做的事情，
when I wasn't doing crossword puzzles and watching the news was sports. I was a very tomboyish kid. So I never really learned how to do hair and makeup, which is not a thing I really was ever good at. So over the last year, when we couldn't have hair and makeup anymore, I have a fabulous glam squad in New York.
除了做纵横字谜和看新闻之外，就是体育。我是一个非常喜欢运动的小女孩。所以我从没真正学会如何化妆和弄头发，这不是我真正擅长的事情。所以在过去的一年里，当我们无法再请发型师和化妆师时，我在纽约有一个了不起的迷人战队。
I couldn't use them. I couldn't use it. We were all locked down in, where we live now in the DMV area. So I got a guy named Fred, he's Fred for Face on Instagram. And he gave me a tutorial. So I was doing my own makeup,
我用不上他们。我用不上。我们都被封锁在——我们现在居住的DMV地区。所以我找到了一个叫弗莱德的人，他在Instagram上叫Fred for Face。他给了我一个教程。所以我当时在自己化底妆，
but when they allowed us to bring hair and makeup back, and also whenever I was in New York, and I would use my hair and makeup folks on the side, they're just brilliant people. So I'm just gonna shout out all of them who are Giselle, who braids my hair. I always get my hair braided in the summer. Giselle the supermodel, incredible.
但当他们允许我们把发型师和化妆师请回来时，而且每当我在纽约时，我都会顺便用我的发型和化妆团队，他们都是极其聪明的 人。所以我只想大声感谢他们所有人，吉赛尔（Giselle），她帮我编辫子。夏天我总是编辫子。超级名模吉赛尔，太不可思议了。
I can't believe it. Giselle Modeste, who is an incredible braider. She did the braids. And then I have CeCe in New York, Michelle in New York, and then here in DC, who does my hair, are Janice, Carmen is the hairstylist, and the third person is Jennifer.
我简直不敢相信。吉赛尔·莫德斯特（Giselle Modeste），她是个了不起的编辫师。她帮我编了辫子。然后我在纽约有茜茜（CeCe），在纽约有米歇尔（Michelle），然后在华盛顿这里帮我做头发的是珍妮丝（Janice）、发型师卡门（Carmen），第三个人是詹妮弗（Jennifer）。
So those are my, that is my glam squad. What's the pre-call on that? I mean, you gotta be on camera. I just didn't worry about call times. This is incredible. Yeah, I just, yeah. This is incredible. It's so light.
所以这些就是我的，这就是我的迷人战队。那个提前召集时间是怎样的？我的意思是，你必须上镜。我只是不担心召集时间。这太不可思议了。对，我只是，对。这太不可思议了。太轻松了。
I think you need 45 minutes. This is the most real that you're getting. This is, we're now at the heart of Bateman. We're at the heart of it. Now we're at the heart of it. This is important. Oh, we're in the engine room. What is the pre-call?
我觉得你需要45分钟。这是你表现得最真实的一次。这是，我们现在来到了贝特曼的核心。我们来到了核心。现在我们来到了核心。这很重要。哦，我们在机舱里。提前召集时间是多久？
What are you in the chair? Actually, what I have to do is I ride, I get in my car, here in DC, I get in my car at 5.15. I have my laptop and I'm working on scripts, working on stuff so I can be in the makeup chair by six o'clock so that I can be done by 6.45. So that's what I do is I make it 45 minutes. And by the way, Carmen, who does my hair,
你什么时候坐在椅子上？其实，我必须做的是，我坐车，在华盛顿这里，我5点15分上车。我带着笔记本电脑，在车里写稿子、处理事情，这样我可以在6点钟坐在化妆椅上，以便在6点45分完成。所以我做的就是把它压缩到45分钟。顺便说一句，帮我做头发的卡门，
we never know what she's gonna do. Neither does she. And she's the makeup and hair team. They just decide in the moment what they feel like based on what I have on. That's so cool. So they're artists. They're true artists.
我们永远不知道她会做什么。她自己也不知道。而她负责化妆和发型团队。他们只是根据我穿的衣服，临时决定他们觉得合适的造型。太酷了。所以他们是艺术家。他们是真正的艺术家。
Outfit drives the hairstyle. Outfit drives. Is that right? The outfit drives the hairstyle. Yeah, and they're vibe. They just catch a vibe. I love it. I love it.
服装决定发型。服装决定。是这样吗？服装决定发型。是的，还有他们的氛围。他们只是捕捉一种氛围。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。
All right, back to the show. Well, let me ask you this. So you're in the car at 5.15. So do you, so what time are you up? Do you have a regime in the morning? Do you work out or are you just straight into the car? We're talking 5.15 in the afternoon. Oh, it's 5.15 in the afternoon.
好了，回到节目。好吧，我问你个问题。所以你下午5点15分在车里。那你，那你几点起床？你早上有什么规律作息吗？你会锻炼，还是直接上车？我们说的是下午5点15分。哦，那是下午5点15分。
Yeah, 5.15 in the afternoon. Because now, you know, we work from home now. Well, because it used to be, you know, you come into the office, we don't do that anymore. We're still basically from home. I just go into the studio right right before the show. But basically I have deep insomnia, very bad insomnia. So if I get, you know, four or five hours of sleep,
对，下午5点15分。因为现在，你知道的，我们现在在家办公。好吧，因为以前，你知道的，你得去办公室，我们现在不那样了。我们基本上还是在家办公。我只是在节目开始前直接去演播室。但基本上我患有严重的失眠，非常严重的失眠。所以如果我能睡，你知道的，四五个小时，
I pop up at like six, seven o'clock, walk my dog, make sure that we have a puppy. So she has to pee immediately in the morning so she doesn't pee in the house. And then I pretty much start reading in, figuring out what's going on. I have three show meetings a day, all by phone, oh, three and a half,
我大概六、七点钟就会醒来，遛遛狗，确保我们有只小狗。所以她早上必须立刻尿尿，这样才不会尿在家里。然后我基本上就开始阅读资料，了解发生了什么。我一天开三个节目会议，全都是通过电话，哦，三个半，
because I have one meeting with my executive producer and senior producer. And then we just sort of sort of chop through what we're gonna do on the show. I try to read in, they get scripts ready. I sometimes write like a rant of my own that they have to edit and work on. What in the world do you do when you aren't doing this?
因为我跟执行制片人和高级制片人有一个会议。然后我们只是顺着梳理一下我们在节目里要做什么。我试着阅读资料，他们准备剧本。有时我自己会写一段长篇大论的抱怨，他们得对其进行编辑和处理。当你不做这些事情的时候，你到底在干什么？
I mean, Honestly, I kind of collapse. Like I work out twice a week. I have a trainer now, because I'm trying to, you know, get in shape because it's summer. So I work out with her twice a week. Are we cross training?
我的意思是，说实话，我有点虚脱。比如我一周锻炼两次。我现在有个教练，因为我在努力，你知道的，锻炼身体，因为现在是夏天。所以我一周跟她锻炼两次。我们在进行交叉训练吗？
Are we, is it aerobic? Is that we pushing weights? I can't do cross training. Yeah, I, you know, I'm not, I can't cross training. It's basically an intensive 30 minute workout twice a week, which is both weights, weights, body weight, and aerobic and aerobic stuff. So it's like very intense 30 minutes that kills me.
我们在，这是有氧运动吗？我们在举重吗？我做不了交叉训练。对，我，你知道的，我不是，我做不了交叉训练。基本上这是一场高强度的30分钟锻炼，一周两次，既有重量训练，重量，自体体重，还有有氧运动和有氧内容。所以就像是非常折磨我的高强度30分钟。
Will is willing to teach you boxing. Yeah, I'm on the boxing. I love boxing, by the way. I mean, I'm obsessed with boxing. I was a huge Muhammad Ali fan growing up. So I will totally get it. I have, well, mine's less Muhammad Ali and more like, you know,
威尔愿意教你拳击。对，我在学拳击。顺便说一句，我超爱拳击。我的意思是，我对拳击着迷。我小时候是穆罕默德·阿里的超级粉丝。所以我完全能接受。我，好吧，我的没那么像穆罕默德·阿里，更像是，你知道的，
Boom, boom, man, see me? Beverly Hills house husband. Oh, got it. No, I'm just like, don't worry guys, I got this bang and then I get knocked out immediately. You know what I mean? When you were younger, what was your sport? What are you watching?
砰，砰，伙计，看到我了吗？贝弗利山庄居家男人。哦，明白了。不，我只是像，别担心，伙计们，我搞定这个，然后我马上就被击倒了。你知道我的意思吗？你年轻的时候，你的运动是什么？你在看什么？
So when I started out being a huge baseball fanatic, I used to have a baseball card collection. I was that serious. But I became like an ultimate football, yeah, football and basketball. So I was a Denver Broncos fanatic. Like I would literally cry if they lost. I was literally a fanatical football fan
所以我刚开始是个狂热的棒球迷，我以前收集过棒球卡。我就是那么认真。但我后来成了超级橄榄球迷，对，橄榄球和篮球。所以我曾是丹佛野马队的狂热粉丝。如果他们输了，我甚至会哭。我简直是个狂热的橄榄球迷，
and I was a Nick fan, even though I was supposed to be a Nuggets fan. So I was born in New York. So I was a New York Knicks for life, you know, they broke my heart every year. And the Denver Broncos, but also baseball. I was a Yankee fan, sorry. Okay.
而且我是尼克斯队的粉丝，尽管我本该是掘金队的粉丝。所以我出生在纽约。所以我一辈子都是纽约尼克斯队的粉丝，你知道的，他们每年都让我心碎。还有丹佛野马队，但也包括棒球。我是洋基队的粉丝，抱歉。好吧。
Wow. So then Bill Bradley, did you ever get near, I'm saying his name, right? Right? The Congressman that used to be a Nick? Oh, I never met him. No, yeah. He, and I never, I never got a chance to meet him.
哇。那么比尔·布拉德利，你有没有接近过，我没说错他的名字吧？对吧？那个曾经是尼克斯球员的国会议员？哦，我从未见过他。不，对。他，我从来没有，我从来没有机会见过他。
But I did, we used to go to training camps. So my mom was a professor at University of Northern Colorado and Greeley is where they would do training camp for the Broncos. So I did get to meet a bunch of the Broncos cause we would go out to training camp, which was pretty cool. Got it.
但我确实，我们过去常去训练营。所以我的妈妈是北科罗拉多大学的教授，格雷利就是野马队进行训练营的地方。所以我确实有机会见到了一群野马队的队员，因为我们会去训练营，这真的很酷。明白了。
Got it. You still follow baseball? You're still your Yankee fan? No, I've fallen, here's what happened. Then I had kids and I fell off of sports. Like I don't have time because I'm so busy between family and work and I have two podcasts and I'm writing a third book and I am exhausted.
明白了。你还关注棒球吗？你还是你的洋基队粉丝吗？不，我已经脱粉了，事情是这样的。后来我有了孩子，我就不再关注体育了。比如我没有时间，因为我在家庭和工作之间忙得不可开交，我有两个播客，我正在写第三本书，我筋疲力尽。
And so I don't even have time. I watched a little of the NBA finals. Yeah, I'm too tired. Jason, you're the same, right? You got kids, so you just gave up sports and stuff, right? Yes, yeah, yeah, yeah. It's been all my free time. If I'm not talking to you guys, I'm talking to my kids.
所以我连时间都没有。我看了恩多一点NBA总决赛。是的，我太累了。杰森，你也是一样吧？你也有孩子，所以你就不看体育之类的了，对吧？是的，对，对，对。这占了我所有的空闲时间。如果我不是在跟你们说话，我就是在跟我的孩子们说话。
Just about how it's been. And you don't follow any of the sports anymore, right? You gave it all up just like I did? Yeah, no, just I need to be with my kids. But you gotta love LeBron James. I follow LeBron, I love him. He's like the Muhammad Ali of today. He was just on the show.
就在谈论这些情况。然后你不再关注任何体育运动了，对吧？你像我一样全都放弃了吗？对，不，只是我需要陪我的孩子们。但你一定很喜欢勒布朗·詹姆斯。我关注勒布朗，我爱他。他就像当今的穆罕默德·阿里。他刚刚上过这个节目。
We just had him on the show. And he's just an angel. Oh my God, I love that guy. He's the coolest. I mean, he's the guy, he's like doing it the way you should do it. He's showing everybody because he's playing at the top of his game and then in his free time
我们刚刚请他上了节目。他简直就是个天使。哦天哪，我太喜欢那家伙了。他是最酷的。我的意思是，他是那种人，他是按照你应该去做的方式在做这件事。他向所有人展示了这一点，因为他在他职业生涯的巅峰时期表现出色，然后在他的空闲时间，
and what he does and how, not just that he's giving back, but how he does it and how he's making a difference is setting a whole new standard. Incredible guy, incredible guy. And I think he respects me a lot too. That's not what somebody said. I talked to him.
以及他做的事情和方式，不仅是他懂得回馈，而是他如何做到这一点以及他如何带来改变，这树立了一个全新的标准。不可思议的家伙，不可思议的家伙。而且我想他也挺尊重我的。这不是别人说的。我和他聊过。
No, it seemed like he respected me a ton. It seemed like he was. Now, what are your show, when you do spend, because you don't have a lot of downtime, it's crazy all the stuff that you're doing. What do you do? Do you have shows that you, what are the things that you like to watch?
不，看起来他非常尊重我。看起来他就是。那么，你的节目，当你确实有时间的时候，因为你没有多少空闲时间，你所做的所有事情真是疯狂。你都做什么？你有什么节目，你喜欢看什么东西？
What are the movies that you like to watch? So I literally like, I'm a TV kid because I'm a generation exer, so I grew up watching, coming home, watching Star Trek. And if I wasn't watching sports, I love TV. So I watch a lot of Netflix. Right now I'm watching a series called Frequency, which is really, really good.
你喜欢看什么电影？所以我字面上的意思是，我是一个电视儿童，因为我是X世代，所以我从小看着，放学回家看《星际迷航》。如果我没有在看体育节目，我非常喜欢电视。所以我看很多网飞。现在我正在看一个叫《黑洞频率》的系列剧，真的非常非常好看。
But I love anything with zombies, superheroes, action, adventure. Are you walking dead gal? Walking dead, yes. I didn't like Fear the Walking Dead at first, but now I'm into it. So yeah, walking dead, totally into it. But I hate Negan though.
但我喜欢任何有僵尸、超级英雄、动作、冒险的题材。你是《行尸走肉》的铁粉吗？《行尸走肉》，是的。我一开始不喜欢《行尸之惧》，但现在我迷上了。所以，是的，《行尸走肉》，完全迷上了。但我讨厌尼根。
He's handsome, but I hate him. You go see a baseball game with Jason. And then when we get home, you and I watch all of those things. Yes. Because everything you just said is everything I love. You do love Star Trek, Shawn. I love it, right?
他很帅，但讨厌他。你会和杰森一起去看棒球比赛。然后等我们回家，你和我一起看所有这些东西。是的。因为你刚才说的一切都是我最喜欢的。肖恩，你确实喜欢《星际迷航》。我喜欢，对吧？
I love all of it. Shawn loves space stuff, and he loves sci-fi. Shawn, we're gonna survive the zombie apocalypse because see people like put us down for watching zombies, but when the zombie apocalypse comes, we're gonna know what to do. What about World War Z? Did you see World War Z?
我喜欢所有这些。肖恩喜欢太空的东西，他喜欢科幻。肖恩，我们会在僵尸末日中生存下来，因为你看人们因为我们看僵尸而瞧不起我们，但当僵尸末日来临时，我们会知道该怎么做。那《二战僵尸》呢？你看过《僵尸世界大战》吗？
Yeah, that was a good movie. Oh my God, yes, of course. One of the best movies ever. Well, I saw that too. 28 days later, 28 days later. 28 days later is great too, yeah. I love Brad Pitt. Don't you?
对，那是一部好电影。哦天哪，是的，当然。有史以来最好的电影之一。好吧，我也看过那个。《惊变28天》，《惊变28天》。《惊变28天》也很棒，是的。我喜欢布拉德·皮特。你不喜欢吗？
Yeah, you've seen them all? Well, what's your favorite Brad Pitt movie, Will? Well, Once Upon a Time in Hollywood, but it's the current one because he looks great, but he's so cool, and he's a good dude. And everybody relax, Brad's fine. You know the best Brad Pitt movie is Snatch. Isn't that the name Snatch?
是的，你都看过？好吧，你最喜欢的布拉德·皮特电影是什么，威尔？嗯，是《好莱坞往事》，但这是最近的一部，因为他看起来很棒，但他太酷了，而且他是个好人。大家别紧张，布拉德很好。你知道最好的布拉德·皮特电影是《偷抢拐骗》吗？那个名字是不是叫《偷抢拐骗》？
It's a British movie. Yeah, that was great. Yeah, that's the best Brad Pitt. That's a good one. I mean, it's a long list, Joy. Let's be real. A bunch of true romance. Yeah, Me Joe Black.
这是一部英国电影。对，那部很棒。对，那是最好的布拉德·皮特。那是一部好片。我的意思是，这是一个很长的名单，乔伊。说真的。还有《第六感生死恋》。对，还有《黑夜之神》。
People have put it down, but I love Me Joe Black. Don't sleep on Me Joe Black for sure. He lives with Anthony Williams. I like California. Jersey, California with Juliette Lewis. California was a good one too, with Juliette Lewis, yeah. Yeah, so good. I love movies.
人们贬低它，但我爱《第六感生死恋》。千万别小看《黑夜之神》。他和安东尼·威廉姆斯一起住。我喜欢《加州杀手》。朱丽叶特·刘易斯的《加州杀手》。《加州杀手》也是部好片，由朱丽叶特·刘易斯主演，是的。对，太棒了。我爱电影。
I love movies and TV, so yeah. Anything, any kind of entertainment. The only thing I don't really like are like romances, which is probably really ungurly, but. Yeah, a little rom-com or. Kind of a bit boring. Yeah, I know. You don't like the romance stuff?
我爱电影和电视，所以，是的。任何东西，任何类型的娱乐。我唯一不喜欢的是爱情片，这可能真的很不像个女汉子，但。是的，有点浪漫喜剧或者。有点无聊。对，我知道。你不喜欢爱情片？
It's a little YA, right? They get a bit boring. Yeah, a little predictable. You know they're gonna be together and. You know what's gonna happen, right? I'm like, is somebody gonna get murdered anytime soon? Am I gonna see like a, you know? Is there gonna be a fight?
有点像青少年文学，对吧？它们变得有点无聊。对，有点老套。你知道他们会在一起，而且。你知道会发生什么，对吧？我就在想，什么时候会有人被谋杀？我会看到像一个，你知道的？会有打斗吗？
Have you watched the Ozarks, the thing? Don't bait her into that. So I keep on being told to watch it. Is it worth it? Is it good? Yeah, I know. Don't know. No, it's not.
你看过《黑钱胜地》那个剧吗？别引诱她跳进那个坑里。所以人们一直叫我去看。这值得看吗？好看吗？对，我知道。不知道。不，不好。
Honestly, because you don't have a lot of time. You don't have a ton of time. And it's super blue. And Sean had told me one time, I said, Sean, I said, Sean, do you like it? And he said, it's okay. You know what I mean? Like he said it like that.
说实话，因为你没有太多时间。你没有大把的时间。而且它的基调非常忧郁。肖恩曾经跟我说过一次，我对肖恩说，肖恩，我说，你喜欢吗？他说，还可以。你知道我的意思吗？就像他那样说的。
It's okay. Yeah. That's a great, Sean Hayes. That's a great. Well, listen, we're gonna end on that. It's a high note. It's, we're gonna end on the high note. It's more of a medium note.
还可以。对。太棒了，肖恩·海斯。这太棒了。好吧，听着，我们要以此结束。这是一个高潮。这是一个，我们要以高潮结束。这更像是一个中音。
But that's a good. Joy, Joy, I get where you got your name from. Listen, we have really enjoyed it. And thank you for sharing your part of your Saturday with us. Yeah, it's so nice. You guys are awesome. I'm a fan and it's been fun hanging out with y'all. So thank you.
但那是个好。乔伊，乔伊，我明白你名字的来历了。听着，我们真的很享受。谢谢你跟我们分享你周六的一部分时间。对，太好了。你们太棒了。我是个粉丝，和你们在一起玩得很开心。所以谢谢。
Likewise. Thank you, Joy. Thank you for taking the time on your Saturday. Thank you for doing this. I appreciate it. See you on the TV Monday. Cool. Bye, Joy.
彼此彼此。谢谢你，乔伊。谢谢你占用你周六的时间。谢谢你做这一切。我很感激。周一电视上见。酷。再见，乔伊。
It's cocktail time. Bye, bye, bye, bye. See you later. Bye, thank you. Bye. Will, look at that. Listener, Will just put his hands behind his head. He wants to talk a little bit, I guess,
到鸡尾酒时间了。再见，再见，再见，再见。回头见。再见，谢谢。再见。威尔，看那个。听众朋友们，威尔刚刚把双手枕在脑后。我想他想聊一会儿，
and show us the gun show. He's completely flexing right now. Look at that. I'm not flexing, dude. I'm just being in a, I'm in a natural position, man. Wait, did you put a blow, did you get put a blow dryer to your pits? They're not as wet as they usually are.
向我们展示他的肌肉秀。他现在完全在秀肌肉。看那个。我没有秀肌肉，老兄。我只是处于一个，我处于一个自然的姿势，老兄。等等，你是不是给你的咯吱窝用吹风机吹了？它们不像平时那么湿。
I always get sweaty pit. Look at that. It's coming through my, my hoodie. I don't sweat except when I do the podcast. Every single... But Jason, why are you wearing a hoodie? It's inside. Why are you wearing a t-shirt?
我总是咯吱窝出汗。看那个。它都渗透到我的，我的卫衣里了。我不出汗，除了我做播客的时候。每一个... 但是杰森，你为什么穿着连帽衫？这是在室内。你为什么穿着T恤？
Just cause it's part, it's just my, it's these are my PJs, bro, you know. But wait, can I say something? First of all, Joy Reed, what a joy. And she is... Very joyful. Yeah. I could hang out with her.
只是因为它一部分，这只是我的，这些是我的睡衣，老兄，你知道的。但是等等，我能说点什么吗？首先，乔伊·里德，真是个开心果。而且她... 非常欢乐。对。我可以和她一起玩。
I could hang out with her like a zombie shit for a long time. Yeah. Do you think you guys would be, I think that you and she would be friends, Sean. Absolutely. I'm going to call her after this. You're going to call her.
我可以跟她像僵尸那样玩很久。对。你觉得你们俩会，我觉得你和她会成为朋友，肖恩。当然。我一会儿要给她打电话。你要给她打电话。
I'm going to call her. Why not? When I'm down in Florida next time, I'll look for her. She's not in Florida anymore. No, she lives in DC. Washington. I thought she was in New York,
我要给她打电话。为什么不呢？下次我再去佛罗里达的时候，我会去找她。她不在佛罗里达了。不，她住在华盛顿特区。华盛顿。我以为她在纽约，
then moved to Florida. You have to listen to the interview back. Oh. She lives in the, in DMV, like DC, Maryland, Virginia area. I have to point that out where that is on the map for me. I like that.
然后搬到了佛罗里达。你得回听一下那个采访。哦。她住在DMV地区，就像DC、马里兰、弗吉尼亚一带。我得在地图上指出那是哪里。我喜欢这样。
I like something she's like, look, I'm an opinion journalist. Like I like that she sort of owns it the way that instead of sort of, you know, having that hung around her neck as a thing. She's like, yeah, I'm right. Yeah, it's my opinion, which I think is really fucking rad. She just lets it loose.
我喜欢她那种，看，我是一个观点记者。就像我喜欢她那种大大方方承认这一点的态度，而不是把这个像个包袱一样挂在脖子上。她就觉得，是的，我是对的。是的，这是我的观点，我觉得这他妈太酷了。她只是畅所欲言。
Yeah. That was a great guest, Jason. She's really cool. I thank you. I hope I wasn't too starstruck because I just, I mean, I think that she and all her colleagues over there are just doing such an incredible job of things. Yeah.
对。那是个很棒的嘉宾，杰森。她真的很酷。我谢谢你。希望我没有表现得太像个狂热崇拜者，因为我只是，我的意思是，我认为她和她那边的所有同事都在做着如此不可思议的工作。对。
I mean, I've just been, as you know, the last few years now, I've kind of stopped DVRing a lot of those shows because I ended up not feeling great. I think that those people are really good at what they do. I want to say that they're all really smart and great. But for me personally, it was just starting to make me not feel great all the time.
我的意思是，就像你所知道的，过去几年里，我已经基本上不再用硬盘录像机录很多那类节目了，因为我最后感觉不太好。我认为那些人非常擅长他们所做的事情。我想说他们都非常聪明且优秀。但对我个人而言，那开始让我经常感觉不太好。
Yeah. It's a lot coming at you for the last, you know, three, four, five, six years. It is. And Jason, we've had this argument before, not even argument, like you've joked and be like, oh, do you prefer to have your head in the sand? And it's not, it's not that.
对。在过去，你知道的，三、四、五年、六年里，有太多信息向你涌来了。确实如此。杰森，我们以前有过这个争论，甚至算不上争论，就像你曾开玩笑说，哦，你是不是宁愿把头埋在沙子里？并非如此，并不是那样的。
I do sort of keep it up. I keep up with stuff, but I keep it in my peripheral vision. I keep it very blurry. I mean, I take it pretty seriously and hard too, but you, I remember, you remember the, I think it was the only episode I ever directed of Arrested Development.
我确实算是关注着。我关注着事情，但我把它们放在我的余光里。我让它们变得非常模糊。我的意思是，我也挺严肃和艰难地对待这件事的，但你，我记得，你记得那次，我想那是我执导《发展受阻》的唯一一集。
It was the day, it was the day that, was it Bush that got elected? It was the second time, yeah, when he beat... He got reelected. When he got reelected, when he beat... Kerry. Kerry, right? Yeah.
那是那天，那是那天，是布什当选的那天吗？那是第二次，对，当他击败... 他连任了。当他连任时，当他击败了... 克里。克里，对吧？对。
And you came to work that morning. It was a big, big day we were shooting, and I was directing, so I was very, very stressed out. Jason, do you remember, do you remember the scene? Yeah. It was me in the banana suit. Yeah, picked up on a crane and dropped in the marina. Not just that.
然后你那天早上来上班。那是我们拍摄的一个非常非常大的日子，而且我在导演，所以我非常非常紧张。杰森，你还记得，你还记得那个场面吗？对。是我穿着香蕉服。对，被吊车吊起然后扔进码头。不仅如此。
We, you and I got into a little tiff, because you were mad, because I was so in such a bitter mood. Yeah, he shows up all bummed out. You didn't even have citizenship yet. I know, at that point... And he's showing up all bummed out about the American election.
我们，你和我起了一点小争执，因为你很生气，因为我情绪那么糟糕。对，他一出现就垂头丧气的。你当时甚至还没有公民身份呢。我知道，在那时... 而他一出现就为美国大选垂头丧气。
I'm like, guy, we got a full day of work. I was your understudy, I was the second banana. Oh, fuck. That's high quality. Fuck, is that good? That's why Sean gets the big bucks. That is unbelievable. Say that one more time.
我就像，老兄，我们有一整天的工作要做。我是你的替补演员，我是个二流货色。哦，操。那是高质量。操，这个好吗？这就是肖恩拿大钱的原因。这太难以置信了。再说一遍。
Sure. I was your understudy, so I was known as the second banana. You guys get that? Fuck, let's just talk show quick, right? It is so good. Yeah, it's really, really good. Thanks, you guys.
当然。我是你的替补演员，所以我被称为二流货色。你们听懂了吗？操，我们快聊节目吧，好吗？真的太好了。对，真的非常非常好。谢谢你们，伙计们。
Anyway, getting back to Joy, what I think was so amazing about her is her ability to, she seems to give genuine time and consideration to both sides, right? Republican, which would really technically make her, bye. Bye, partisan.
无论如何，回到乔伊，我认为她最厉害的地方在于她能够对双方都给予真诚的时间和考虑，对吧？共和党，这从技术上讲会让她，拜。拜。党派。
Partisan, bye. Bye. Partisan. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
党派，拜。拜。党派。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。